all right hey everybody welcome back to
our astro coffee
bookshelf hangout my name is tony
darnell and i run deepastronomy.com and
we are
back again after a brief hiatus over the
summer to do different things uh brian
had things to do i had things to do and
now we're back
not doing things so today let me pull my
co-host up
dr brian keating is with us and joins us
because the purpose of these hangouts
is to introduce you to new books and new
publications that have
been made available in the world of
astronomy and science and
brian has a wonderful blog a blog po
podcast and youtube channel the links of
all of that are in the description box
of this video
if you're watching this on deep
astronomy please follow him and his
channel on youtube
and uh he has access to some amazing
interviews and authors and all kinds of
stuff the most recent of which well
maybe not the most recent but the one
we're going to talk about today is his
conversation with
andrea the co-creator of cosmos and
and i has her has her
life involved in many different aspects
of the world of science communication
and she is also the wife of the late
carl sagan so welcome brian it's good to
have you back
oh hang on yes i'm trying to figure out
why you're not live
oh you see me the sound is good good
okay you hear me i believe so
all right my volume is low all right
i'll turn my volume back up
there it's louder there we go testing
testing one two three okay
have my volume that should be better
folks okay
good my volume is low too quiet volume
up no thank you nuki
okay everybody the volume's up stop
chatting about it okay
okay back to back to so tell us about
your conversation uh brian tell us first
of all give us
we can't always assume everybody's
watching every week that knows what
we're doing so
introduce yourself talk about what
you're doing and in particular the topic
of today
yeah so i'm brian keating a professor of
uh physics and astronomy at university
of california san diego
and i also run the into the impossible
podcast which is a production of the
arthur c
clarke center for human imagination a
lot of a lot of vowels there a lot of
words there
uh but the mission of the clark center
is really to bring the arts and sciences
to the masses to the lay people and we
have incredible guests
on the show it's an interview show
typically there's auth there are authors
who are my guests
but not always and in fact this week i
had none other than gnome chomsky the
most
cited academic in human history just
because he
came about during the 20th century on
the advent of media
but i think his citation count is a
million or so
which is uh a hundred times what mine is
uh
so we had an amazing conversation which
you can find on my youtube channel which
is just my
initial my name here dr brian keating
and i'll put links to it and we had a
fantastic conversation this week
including the linguistics
of communicating with alien species if
you can believe that he's a
the father of linguistics essentially
cognitive science
professor at mit for 60 years and
uh was gracious enough now to take some
time out of his uh
very active retirement or maybe he's
still
actually quite active at university of
arizona where he is currently
located and uh we talked for almost two
hours so
i'll put a link to to my channel and
people can go over there
from your channel check that out but
this week
i talked to our published interviewer
actually was last week with andrean
uh who is the author of uh many books
cosmos possible worlds
is her latest book and it's based on the
series cosmos which is now
the and the implementation that's called
cosmos possible worlds is the third
season they're calling it
uh there's a lot of time between seasons
it's not like binge watching on netflix
first season was 1980 with carl sagan
season two was in 2014 with
uh neil degrasse tyson as the on-air
host and he will return in the fall in
september
september 23rd i believe it is for a
reprise as the host in cosmos possible
worlds
allegedly you can stream it now but i
talked to
to andrewian for an hour and a half or
so
uh about a month ago and we just had an
amazing conversation about this book and
so i really want to get into this book
and some of the novelty that i found in
it um and
also the kind of standard questions i
always ask of my guests
in particular this time was nice because
she's the
uh first time we've had on a
mother-daughter duo we had on sasha
sagan
you and i talked about that about a
month ago i had her on on mother's day
and i had andrewian on around father's
day
but it was nice to have the first
mother-daughter duo and i
made sure to make a reservation for
andrean's daughter
uh sasha has a daughter named helena
and i'm i'm already pre-booking her
granddaughter on the show for
20 37 so stay tuned for that
okay well tell us about the book then so
the book
is uh really fascinating it's one of
these books it's actually
uh you can get it relatively uh
easily available even though the book is
uh the the series is not out for several
months
uh you can get it in one of two ways you
can buy it yourself or you can enter a
contest
that i am running and i hope people will
do this i'm going to put a link to the
contest
so i'm running a contest a giveaway uh
for this book
and it's very simple you can get a bunch
of offer a bunch of entries
in this contest to get a free copy of
this book shipped to you
unfortunately it's only for us residents
or apo
post office boxes but this um but this
contest is really
uh you know to to to get uh to get
people excited about this series that's
coming up and
best news of all tony she's agreed to
come to ucsd
for an event possibly around the launch
of cosmos possible worlds on national
geographic and fox
this fall so i couldn't be more pleased
with the way the conversation
turned out so i really encourage people
to enter the contest
and um and and also to uh
to stay tuned for this incredible
opportunity to win a book this
uh this book so what does the book cover
it covers the many different ways in
which the word
you know possible world could be
interpreted so one of those
is actually physical other earths other
life-supporting planets
that may exist may have existed in the
past we talked last time
last year in june about this famous
paper with
36 and we were both steamed that it
wasn't 42 possible civilizations
yeah that my friends you can say 42.
right
and that uh that was this um that was
this uh you know
um calculation by christopher consoles
who's a friend of mine
uh about worlds that could have existed
or might exist now
with the nearest one having a maximum
probability of being located
something like uh 17 000 light years
away from earth so
actual planets in which life could exist
and then
uh notions of life that has existed
perhaps previously
on planet earth and then the last time
which she didn't really get into as much
although she thought it was a
fascinating thing to talk about was the
actual
possible worlds that carl sagan has
inculcated through
the inspiration that he's had for
millions of us around the world
to uh to pursue astronomy wonder
the scientific method and in particular
her children nick and sasha
who are actually co-producers or co-you
know
participants in the cosmos series so i
call them the first family of the cosmos
because they're they're really such
incredible intellects
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
they certainly aren't that's certainly
true with
uh introducing the cosmos to people
that's that's most definitely true so
um well what so what is the
use what was the the the second thing
that you were talking about
the uh about the meaning of possible
worlds this idea
yeah well what was that again because i
caught just a part of that phrase and i
want to make sure i understand
all of it it's it's sort of you know
thinking about your your
children or the people that you inspire
in your life if you don't have children
to be interested in these grand topics
in the universe the topics including
uh looking for looking for life
elsewhere but also
inculcating values in in people
and sort of this ethical will concept
that i always ask all my guests about
so uh that's almost like a it's a
possible world in the sense that it's
changing ours it's a possible world in
that it's it's you know children come
into the universe kind of as these tabla
rasa
these blank slates that we can influence
uh also they can be
independent obviously and they can be
completely different from us but
how do you implicate values that are
important i pres i
you know propose to anne that that's a
form of the only form of time
translation or teleportation that we
have we can communicate certain values
to our children and to our ideological
offspring if you don't have children i
can loan you some if you need some i got
a bunch but um but if
but they but the point is you know how
do you continue to do good
by inspiring people with the values
and everybody in this channel highly
values science
and the scientific method and how to
implicate that
in future generations is a legacy that
can nucleate
a possible future world yeah yeah but
you could also argue that you know
you're right about when you say
everybody watching this channel is
probably
really into science and in its methods
but it could also be argued that a lot
of damage has been done
and maybe even a contraction of the
interest and trust in science and if i
one of the things i'm very interested in
hearing from someone like ann is
what does she think and maybe perhaps
you talked about this
what does she think about the current
state
of uh respect that science has among
just the general public not not the
people who are interested in science but
just
everybody there seems now more than ever
a need
to listen to what scientists have to say
and yet
i would argue that science communicators
are failing
uh and they're failing badly uh at
getting
at this at this possible world that
she's alluding to
this value you know promoting the values
and the
of critical thinking and and of all the
things that comes with science what
did you get a sense from your
conversation on what she feels about the
current state
uh absolutely yeah yeah i mean this is a
huge theme on the cosmo second season
uh that we talked a lot about uh how the
scientific method works
is there even a scientific method and
and if so
how how does that work to um
to kind of fan the flames of incipient
curiosity
in non-scientists look there's way more
non-scientists than there are scientists
that's exactly right
but everybody has curiosity uh and it
actually is
you know i did a podcast with a guy
named james altucher who's a well-known
you know podcast kind of self-help guru
financial guru and he was on my show for
three hours that's going to come out
soon on my channel dr brian keaton
but uh but the uh thing that he brought
up to me it's kind of a throwaway line
he said that
adults laugh five times a day kids laugh
300 times a day so somewhere along the
line 60 times
you know of our humor is cut out by the
time we get to become adults
and i made the connection between that
and curiosity i
drive my kids to camp uh you know
finally gavin newsom's allowed us to
send our kids
to camp in certain circumstances and in
20 minutes i have two kids in the car
asking about 80 questions and and i
thought like
i never get questions from lay people
you know very rarely compared to that
like
one car ride trip commute to their camp
i could have all the questions that an
adult might ask in a month
and so what her job is very is very
uniquely suited to do she's an excellent
communicator
she makes the point she is not a
scientist she's sci curious
and she's been an ambassador to science
so one of the beautiful things about
this book
you can get it as i said for free if you
win this contest if you enter in the
link that i'm putting in the chat
um but the book is actually a work of
art it's it's sort of a small
coffee table book i usually hate let me
make you big
yeah make me big inflate me to the size
of my ego
we have wonderful illustrations here
that are um are uniquely you know
displaying
uh the glory the beauty of the cosmos
and that's a vector
right a vector to having people children
appreciate the cosmos
involved these things that actually carl
was responsible for so she goes through
his
his kind of um history and how he was
inspired by these grand themes in the
30s hearing
albert einstein you know one of the
first if uh if if not the best
uh popularizers of science he was not
only a genius and a great
uh and a great scientist himself he was
actually one of the first communicators
of science
and what they do beautifully in this
book which is like a coffee table book
but not as an insult it's just
physically beautiful there's no way
somebody can pick this up and not get
drawn in
by some of the images here this is not a
nebula you know
what is this relevance to possible
worlds well it has to do with
with uh the hydrothermal vents that
could produce organic compounds that may
turn into inorganic compounds
there's um there's archaeology in here
and the mixture between
high-tech and there's paleontology
there's looking at uh at extremely high
tech including
her description as we talked about in
the interview
of her brain waves were recorded and
encrypted onto the voyager golden disc
album this is now on a five billion year
long journey
and what were her brain waves processing
were they processing
you know lorenz transformation no she
was thinking about her newly incipient
love for carl sagan they had just met in
1970 something
uh in and they had been falling in love
and she developed this idea that they
would record
her brain waves in an ekg machine and
then the uh
eeg machine and she would use those
brain waves they were encrypted on this
on this record which
i pointed out was really the first
example you ever heard of world music
it's it's a little different than
elevator music but
it's uh we take it for granted now you
hear it like south american pan flute
you hear that
she was really part of the first effort
to ever make
world music and why because they wanted
to make a time capsule and they wanted
to send this time capsule
out into the universe and there was as
much for the benefit
of the future aliens that find it so
that they can know the menu of what
they're going to eat when they come no
i'm just kidding hopefully they're not
going to do that tony
but but it's as much for them as it is
for us and what is meaningful for people
on earth so she's an
artist she's a you know a poet but she's
she's the most
educated kind of lay person in the sense
uh that i've had the benefit
to me even more so than her daughter
actually it's incredibly impressive
i completely believe that i remember
when they were putting that together the
in the late 70s
um when when voyager was launched and we
had gotten all the media about it i was
still in high school at the time and
yeah and i thought it was an amazing
idea um and of course
you know it it was also that same couple
uh
i think i don't know what roland had in
it but of course carl pushed really hard
for voyager to turn around and take a
look at earth when it
yeah when it was way far out there and
that was that was because he
they got it they understood what you had
to do with science missions like this
you needed
to inspire and and give perspective of
our place in the universe and he had at
his disposal these tools
the viking lander the the voyager probes
he's been involved in all kinds books of
course and tv shows
but but the um but the beauty of what
they did is they were such original
thinkers both of them
one of the things being this record that
you just showed
and encrypting it with technology of the
time i i think it's a
it's an acoustic record right you have
it came with a needle
a special needle that had to be played
on a turntable
and there was instructions on that
somewhere on the plaque that showed you
how to put it together
and you had to play it like an lp now we
don't even do that now you know in fact
instructor chat says that he his
signatures on the golden
disc i wonder how that came to be but uh
maybe larry you can put in the con in
the comments how that came to be and uh
definitely i did not know that's really
cool there that's how you do that
and of course that's a tradition they're
still going on nasa lets you
electronically put your name into
various rovers and stuff that go to mars
so that they were the first right and
new horizons they beamed a bunch of
signatures etc
out into the universe um out to new
horizons on the occasion of it uh making
contact with pluto
how active is anne in social media i
don't
think she's that i mean i i follow a lot
of people i don't think she
i don't know right no she has no
president what
sort of what does she have is that a
statement about how she feels about
social media or can she just not be
bothered
i i think you know she's she's a certain
demographic you know um
that's not quite as savvy as others you
know it's funny because her son
nick is on twitter and then he tweeted
out a tweet from someone named denzel
washington
and denzel uh but it's a parody account
so
he didn't realize it even and i was
realizing because i heard a
an interview with um one of my chief
competitors in the podcast circuit is of
course oprah winfrey i mean she's always
looking over her shoulder at me
she has a wonderful interview with kevin
hart the comedian
and he was kind of like making the
distinction between new media people
like him himself
and then people like in the old guard
like denzel washington and then i come
up on this quote by you know carl
sagan's son
nick retweeting someone named denzel
washington
who's not really denzel washington so it
was just funny to to kind of uh have
this
i think yeah i think we'd all be more
productive if we were
you know she she doesn't need to she's
the co-producer she's the writer
she does so many things um and they have
a fourth season i am told in the works
as well
uh and even even longer into the future
and this partnership with neil
is just uh is just going gangbusters for
both right it seems to be really he
does the social media that i mean
there's no way i made the point to
somebody
recently because he's a friend of a
friend uh he was like the advisee of a
of one of my close colleagues at
princeton uh for his postdoc
i believe and uh i was making the case
to him you know that he is the most
famous scientist in history neil
degrasse tyson because
no he is it still goes no still goes to
einstein i don't
know but i'm just saying in terms of
people that know about him
yeah i mean einstein didn't live during
the era of meteor media popularization
that we have today in terms of like who
can pick up you know who would a
scientist be who would recognize it yes
einstein might be more and he's
certainly more of an actual practicing
scientist than neil is as neil fully
admits
but nevertheless i'm just making the
point that social media has taken
scientists
into the realm of celebrity okay this is
a question for you personally brian not
not about anne or not from for ann or
what she might have said but
what do you think about the
uh role of social media in our ability
to communicate science and do you think
personally that if carl were alive now
he would be active on social media
i think he would i mean the the the
foundation that he started the planetary
society bill nye is the
current director of that he's extremely
active uh
neil degrasse tyson who is one of carl's
you know kind of uh motivations for
getting into popularizing science
i think he would be the question is you
know how much did he suffer
for being the neil degrasse tyson of his
day because
unlike neil again neil fully admits this
i'm not telling tales at a school i love
neil and everything he does
even though he won't return calls to be
on my podcast but that's another side
but someday i'll get him someday i'm
sure i'll get him i spoke at the hayden
planetarium where he is the director
uh three years ago and ran the
planetarium and i was just really hoping
to meet him
i was hoping to meet my kid's favorite
astrophysicist but it didn't come out to
be
uh so you know when you look at someone
like neil
versus versus carl carl was an actual
practicing you know day-to-day
scientists writing
hundreds of papers and books and editing
and starting societies
i don't know how he found the time but
thank god he did because he didn't live
that long
unfortunately he died in the in the late
90s but he accomplished a tremendous
amount but one thing that i know
sort of irked him was the fact that he
never got elected into the national
academy of science
um for the work that he did in basically
creating the fields of astrobiology and
and contributing to
studies of brown dwarfs working on
nuclear
you know proliferation um you know
disincentivization
uh these things that he did were so you
know so magnanimous and so important
for all of science that all of us
believe nowadays that he should be and
in fact nasa of all their fellowships
that have names after them
uh his is one of the very few einstein
hubble and sagan
and uh there hopefully be a few more um
you know as
as time goes on for women and other
underrepresented groups uh hopefully
uh and carl is up there in the pantheon
and not because he was a popularizer
because he was an amazing scientist
and he suffered for that and nowadays we
talked about this did carl really suffer
you know from going through this uh you
know from kind of being this ambassador
and would he have traded it and i asked
her about you know and she said no
because look at the end of the day if i
write a monumental paper my paper
along with my bicep two colleagues that
set the world on fire
that i describe in my book losing the
nobel prize as evidence for
direct evidence for the first time of
cosmic inflation
the one whose results we later had to or
the claims we later had to retract
that paper got 1500 citations according
to
anne over uh over a million times more
people
saw the series
cosmos cosmos of the second season and
we'll see this one
in other words a billion and a half
people around the world it's just
unbelievable the impact that he had
agreed and i i would say the the
question of his suffering
scientifically may have occurred but it
certainly wouldn't i don't think
happened today and i also believe that
it had he lived longer
he'd be in the national academy right
now um oh yeah i do
and he was also as i've some some of the
biographies i've read
a little miffed about with harvard at
not giving him tenure as well but um
yeah he did all right for himself yeah
certainly and uh like we've talked about
before i followed carl
quite closely in the 80s he was a i was
a big fan of his and
and because of cosmos and uh it was you
know
he had a lot of quirks i saw him on tv a
lot and
you know he made a lot of blunders on
tail on national television and
interviews things like that that
he got him in a lot of trouble because
he was very much against uh
nuclear nuclear war nuclear weaponry i
should say
and uh was very much worried we were
going to wipe ourselves out from that
and so he
was also politically quite active he was
like he was at demonstrations at rocky
flats in colorado i learned about that
because it was just down the road from
where i lived and i tried to see him
um and there was you know all kinds of
uh really cool things that he did he had
no
i i think um i think today um
i agree with you i think he would be in
social media and i think he'd be a rock
star at it i think he'd be
you know every bit as big as as ndt is
uh and now and um i i guess
i guess one thing one thing i want to
try and get out of you though
is a before we have to how much time do
you have by the way i've got plenty of
time
oh good so okay it would sound like a 3
30 cut off or anything
no no i can go to the hour all right
because i'm starting to get upset
okay the level of um
at the level of distrust that i'm seeing
in our lives right now i mean even you
just today said gavin newsom is letting
us
now go out and take our children out you
said that in a way
that was like you're you're finally
being let free
as if you know you you're feeling a
little bit uh
tread upon um yourselves and i get the
frustration
that people have with the way things are
right now and but what science is saying
isn't just made up you know and and i
think
and we've gotten to the point now where
most people in the world people watching
this channel notwithstanding
don't believe it they just you know they
don't believe
science and i actually think very
strongly i'd like to get your thoughts
on this
that social media has damaged science in
particular by the communicators
themselves
uh and i can go into why i think that
but i would like to know instead what
you think about that
comment yeah i mean it's i was kind of
being tongue-in-cheek but
for example eric weinstein who's a great
fan of
of many of the listeners here i mean he
he went off on dr anthony fauci
about three weeks ago for you know this
this
this admission that there was you know
basically a secondary motive behind
telling people not to wear masks in the
beginning
and that was to preserve masks for the
much more needed and important you know
healthcare professionals so
on one hand you know he was saying uh
you know critical of fauci
now i i didn't take uh i didn't take a
position on this but
um and then he's a renowned scientist
it's not like he doesn't believe in
you know that the earth is round uh but
but in other words
i think that the the notion that right
now in the midst of this pandemic you
know we were planning to have an eclipse
trip
down to chile in uh early december
and people are asking me you know the
tour guide company that i was supposed
to work with and blah blah
and and they're like well what do you
think we should do should we ask for the
money back now i'm like
why are you asking a physicist you know
it's not like i
have any special vector or knowledge
about how this
particular and you know what's the
problem is tony and i hate
this about about you my my my
fellow scientists because when i give a
talk
i'll often give a talk at a lions club a
rotary club and i love it i love doing
that because it's like
these are just you know real people like
you know and they're so interested in
science they
but then at the end the q and a they'll
say well global warming you're like tell
me you know like do you feel it's like
the evil oil companies you feel like
it's the it's the tree huggers
and i'll say you know what i hope when
you have um
a an environmental um you know scientist
who comes to give a
talk at your rotary club i hope that you
when you ask him
what do you think is more likely the big
bang or the cyclic model of the universe
i hope that he or she says uh why don't
you ask a cosmologist about that
because i have a feeling they wouldn't
answer that so i always say look i
understand the microphysics
uh but you know there's much bigger
problems and you know what tony i've
seen this
also in the whole black lives matter
debate and i'm not gonna get into
politics here but i will say
um i do have a video from dr sylvester
james gates who's
the first black um phd in from mit
uh to graduate in theoretical physics in
the 70s he's the
upcoming president-elect of the american
physical society
and he has a video blog on my channel dr
brian keating on youtube
and he talks about the progression of
society
with regard to african americans and the
uh the this
you know discrimination that he's faced
and that progress that's being made
and i feel like and i asked him about
this why are they asking physicists
about how to make social policy and and
defunding the police and or extra fun
they shouldn't be asking us we're not
experts in that tony we're experts in in
our subject matter expertise so you know
what we did instead
we said how can we make fellowships that
go
for historically black colleges for
students at her store
to participate in the simon's
observatory to work in cosmology at the
at the flatiron institute to learn from
the greatest and be
partners with us not students they're
partners with us
so we're working with the american
physical society the national society
of black physicists to do the only thing
that we can do which is to make physics
more inclusive but through physics not
through like
uh brian keating you give a you know
what about what i think about social
policy no
right you should only care about what i
say about cosmology that's right and
it's easy when you're a science
communicator to get caught up in this
you're being asked your opinion on all
kinds of stuff
and you feel like okay i've got an
opinion on this so let's
give it look they asked einstein to be
the president of israel the first
president
he said like what are you talking about
that's called the halo bias
the halo effect just because he's smart
in one realm
doesn't mean anything about his
capability and capacity in a completely
orthogonal direction
i really dislike that i know and so let
me just highlight simon farmer's comment
i've got 60
science youtube subscriptions that uh
that disagree
with your notion that science
communicators are failing well okay let
me ask you this
scion to whom are those 60 channels
talking to is it all the like
are they all preaching to the choir and
when i say science communicators are
failing i'm not talking about
doing a good job communicating science
i'm talking about
they're not they're failing when they
talk about things that aren't about
science
and they can even get downright
belligerent to those who don't agree
with them
look at all kinds of channels
thunderf00t comes to mind everybody
loves him
but he's belligerent to people who don't
believe in what
he believe in science of any kind um and
there are
you know there's tons of other examples
out there of people who are
great at science communicating but feel
the need to talk about things
richard dawkins how about him right
let's talk about religion
in what way is he even remotely
qualified to do that and what that does
is it it ruins your credibility
among those who don't who to who don't
know anything about science credentials
right so why would they trust you if
you're going to sit there and attack
them
for some let's say i'm not i have no
know nothing about science but i have
emotionally uh charged beliefs about
science and the world and religion
and here's this scientist coming at me
as if i'm an idiot
am i going to trust this guy hell no
neil degrasse tyson's done it
and all the really really big science
communicators have felt the need
to denigrate those who are not just you
know
stomping on the uh the the footpath of
science it's called scientism
and it's it's a problem and that's the
point i'm trying to get at
and i believe that the current state of
affairs
for what universe is wearing a mask a
political issue
right and yet here we are how did we get
here
and so we got here in part because of a
distrust in science and i'm trying to
ask brian
where where he thinks that comes from
and and by extension and dream and
it sounds like uh that um you never
really asked that did you talk about
that with her
at all uh this is about the level of
distrust in science in our culture today
well i think she views it uh in some
similar fashion to the way that i
perceive it which is that
you know scientists have an obligation i
believe scientists have an obligation to
communicate what they do
but you know it should also be taken
with the astronomers version of the
hippocratic oath in other words do no
harm
so you can point to peer review you can
point to
studies the problem that i think happens
is that
let me let me take another step back to
where you talked about social media so i
had a conversation
with um i won't use his name but he he's
basically one of the most famous
scientists in the world and a
theoretical physicist
and he said to me uh you know that he
could not he would never go on twitter
he would never go on facebook because he
knows he has new ideas that are
are incipient they're they're about to
come out they're in a tentative state
and he knows that he or his postdoc or
his graduate student she could be up
there
on the board at a seminar and people
taking pictures of it posting it
you know oh this is stupid the universe
began like this the universe ends like
that
and it could be extremely detrimental
to the to the fanning of these flames
that for
theoretical ideas they need to be
nurtured for a little bit especially
when they're iconoclastic when they're
breaking the maverick mold of
of what the heterodox or sorry the
orthodoxy is currently
and so i think there is this there is
this problem look like any tool
i think uh ann and others believe that
the
that there could be good or bad use of
of of technology
that is you know in the form of social
media i mean first of all to get stuff
like this out
uh i have a big announcement at the end
of today's talk that i'll
that i'll present i couldn't get that
out you know
to to millions of people if i was in the
past again
if i get that paper that announced the
uh detection of
gravitational waves imprinting the
cosmic ray background polarization and
losing the nobel prize
that got 1500 citations as i said uh
you're lucky on a normal paper is
considered renowned
if it has 500 citations if i if
only 500 people read my book i mean i
don't care about the financial aspects
of it
but i feel like i've failed in a certain
sense not because i really want to be
popular but because i want these ideas
to be influential
so that i can hopefully inspire the next
generation i
always use that idea so to the extent
that
you know my ideas have influenced people
from pakistan to uganda
to you know chile to california i take
that as the number one metric of what
i'm doing
and then in science i already have
metrics i already have uh promotions or
awards or citations it's very
uh highly monitored because we say you
know you cannot measure
you cannot manage what you cannot
measure so it makes sense but
uh i agree with you uh but the problem
is do you could you create i'll turn it
to you
do you create like here's the party here
are the facts and then you rely on
on uh popularity of an idea i mean don't
forget
if you had asked people a hundred years
ago you know as the universe all 97
percent of scientists would agree the
universe is infinitely old
does that make it right no um but i
think you know and
is there room for denialism that's where
you get to a much more slippery slope in
that you know does free speech
apply to everybody of course but you
know should some ideas receive more
attention than others
uh i i like to think that you know if it
does no harm
it's okay but you're making the point
with respect to masks the science seems
to be quite clear so
perhaps it does do harm well no the
point the
that is a symptom of a much bigger
problem and and
in putting it back to me the science
communication that happens
is generally of a very high quality when
it's done
uh you know within its intended audience
but you're never going to get the
broader persp these people all science
communicators we're all basically
looking at the same ten thousand hundred
thousand views right
we're getting the same people we're all
subscribed to the same science channels
we all watch the same videos
because we love science we want to learn
more we want to expand our knowledge
it's the ones that manage to break out
of that the ndt's the
the the richard dawkins and the sam
harris's that can get out there
beyond that bubble and start saying
things they're the ones doing the damage
and carl sagan would have been one of
those types of communicators
everybody knew carl and i don't think he
would have been guilty of that
he did not he was not a religious person
we know that from his from his works
but i cannot see him going out there and
calling people who believe in god fools
or just you know bronze age idiots and
all of this other stuff i can't imagine
him doing that and that's where the
damage starts
and then of course we have politics and
all the other crap that comes out of
this today
all of it related to a lot of factors so
i'm oversimplifying it
a bit well yeah one thing one thing that
i'll go ahead and
well i just want to say one thing you
were saying that i i agree with but i
think you're conflating and that is
you talk about your paper citation
numbers and you compare it with who you
can reach in a public
general science book you are actually
engaged
in two very different activities both of
which are hugely important
when you write a scientific paper and it
gets refereed and put into a journal
you are building on the canonical
science knowledge of science
your paper is now part of
the scientific canon that's amazingly
huge
and a huge deal but it's also a huge
uh um it's a huge uh uh
contribution so when and the bot
that body of knowledge has gotten so big
that it's
you you're only appealing to other
experts like you
who know what you're talking about you
don't take the time in your papers
to to define your jargon right you
assume the reader knows
what all of this is right what what uh
polarization
of of gravitational waves and all of
that kind of you know baryonic acoustic
oscillations you don't bother defining
what those are
you just assume the reader knows and so
you wouldn't expect in that respect a
huge audience
unless your paper is truly a discovery
of some kind
renowned yeah yeah you know what i mean
things like relativity or when they
when they when they did the soup the
type 1a supernova expan acceleration of
the universe stuff like that right well
those by definition
are going to be few and far between but
your other work the stuff that you when
you wrote losing the nobel prize you
were appealing to a completely different
group of people and i don't think it's
fair to compare those
i think you by definition need hundreds
of thousands of readers on one hand
where in the other one you're okay if
500 people don't get your paper and
and it's not good and inside it you're
doing pretty damn good as you say
considered authoritative yeah well
that's really good i hope all 100
000 listeners out there do buy my book
because
my kids at camp is pricey and i have to
keep them in masks uh but uh but in all
seriousness yeah it's true sometimes
i'll spend
six months on a on a single caption to a
figure in a scientific paper
whereas i wrote the book in about a year
it was a tremendous amount of work and
the difference is with a book
it's uh it's all on me i didn't have a
ghostwriter i didn't have helper
i had the helpers in a certain sense you
know people doing illustrations which
are all custom but i had to commission
them
i had to pay for them it didn't come
from the publisher
a little known fact is the publisher
doesn't pay for anything they give it to
you
you get an advance you're supposed to
pay for it yourself and so there's
original artwork
and uh and so there's a lot more
self-ownership like you
i really own that book and it's not like
i can say oh i made a blunder let me
blame my graduate student and it was a
peer reviewed it was just your editor
saying yeah
exactly you spilled writing right let's
focus go exactly right so it goes
through editing which
which a lot of you know things don't in
a proposal it doesn't get edited you
typically submit it and then
if there's errors in it so be it um but
what was interesting and i want to get
back to the conversation with anne
uh a couple things really struck me
about this conversation i really want
people to to go view it so you can view
it in the description
on my channel in my channel the
description awesome great
so we talked about two different things
one was this concept of rivalry in
science there were two different
um rivals that carl sagan had the
opportunity to work with and
uh and and this chapter is called the
man of a trillion worlds
uh it's the one with this hubble deep
field and there's two different
astronomers or
one's a physicist one's an astronomer
and there's a quote
from dr gerald kuiper who's the famous
kuiper belt
and the kuiper and carl was writing to
him
about an offer to become a partner an
intern with dr
kuiper at mcdonald's observatory in
texas
and so he accepted this this thing in
1956 when he was 21 years old
and it turns out that this kuiper was a
huge rival
of a man who is at uc san diego named
harold yuri
who won the nobel prize for discovering
um the uh
what's called the deuterium the heavy
partner of
ordinary hydrogen that has a proton and
a neutron
and he talks about um how these two men
were kind of like
bitter rivals with one another and i
won't spoil the fun but kind of going
back and forth and how did carl manage
it's kind of like he was like the child
of divorced parents like he was going
between these two
eminent scientists won a nobel prize
winner one the namesake of
a whole class of you know planetoids way
out in the solar system
uh that have so much impact on literally
on how
life could have formed on earth and and
how
um and how carl was influenced by it but
the human side of him
and like how do you deal with that
you've got two different offers you know
it could be you know my kids get oh i
got invited to a birthday party but now
a more popular kid invited you know
like seeing how carl wrestled with this
it's just so touching and personal
i really love this chapter and not just
because it has this connection to uc san
diego through harold yuri who our
chemistry department is named after
but it also makes this point you know
that these eventually they would come
together in a sense uh
and united through their child their
scientific child
uh which was carl and that carl would
start the first generation
of interdisciplinary scientific research
is called icarus which kind of blended
astronomy
astrophysics planetary science geology
atmospheric science so this is in the
70s it's just amazing that carl did so
much
and and then how this later you know led
to uh
led to work uh that ended up on apollo
and going to the
going to the moon the famous iconic
footprint of buzz aldrin
on uh the first on an alien world and
how both of these men had these
bitter rivalry between them and then the
last thing i want to talk about is just
in terms of scientific communication
another connection to ucsd is our own uh
mario molina
who won the nobel prize uh in part for
his work on
uh chemistry of the ozone layer etc
and how carl's work and work of mario
molina showed that it was possible to
basically eliminate
cfcs carbon uh fluorocarbons or
hydrofluorocarbons and get rid of them
in commercial applications
and that science through communication
through partnership as you're saying
you know really gives and hope that we
can do stuff in terms of
you know preventing or runaway global
warming so it's interesting that carl
was at the nexus of so many of these
different things
and he really played the role of you
know pacifist or peacemaker
and certainly advocating you know for
the against
ever approaching the horrors of of
nuclear winter as he coined the term
and popularized this as only he could so
i think
you know he there aren't there aren't
any people
really like him i mean neil is is
wonderful but carl
just had this this blend that i could
only aspire to as you said
doing the real science that i try to do
and nucleating the next generation of
scientists my graduate students who are
like children to me
and then also inspiring the public
because
you know i i often say like you guys out
there paying my taxes one way or another
either through research grants the
national science foundation
or if you're in california you're paying
part of my salary as a state employee
and i hope to earn your business and i'm
not making profits on any of my sales
but hopefully what i'm doing is
providing
knowledge and wisdom uh that you can
that you can
take to heart and benefit from all the
hard work that you guys put in
in your money and your resources uh to
to give
and trust to me and your children for
those of you who have students here or
elsewhere people like me
it's just the greatest gift to be able
to be a scientist and that's the thing
that really came through is how much he
loved what he did and how tragic his
life was cut short
it really it chokes me up well you know
what i wish you'd do brian i wish
you would i mean the work you're doing
in science is great and you're doing
amazing science communication too but i
wish you'd run for office because
we need we need politicians who think
like this right we do
we need them to understand not just how
science is done but the way you know the
the the mechanics of it but also the
necessity of the funding and why we need
the funding
you know tony it's so funny you know i i
keep my channel politically neutral as i
had on noam chomsky i have on
uh people on the left on the right you
know hopefully on some averages
i know i know hopefully on average it'll
average out to be neutral but i had on
the two
leading candidates for mayor of the city
of san diego
uh on july 4th appropriate for july 4th
and i had on these two candidates
barbara bree and todd gloria they're
both friends of mine
one of them is going to be the mayor of
the eighth largest city in america and i
said
point blank are you going to have a
science advisor where i didn't ask about
like what do you feel about uh
immigration paul i don't care i'm a
stupid physicist
i said look where's san diego's future
in in technology and education and
health care
and are you going to have a science
advisor and they both had to answer that
question so
you know that's of interest mainly to
people i've only gotten 100 views on
each one of those videos
but i think they're important to see how
politicians think and again you know
there's a million and a half people that
live here but but to answer your actual
request
i i have so much more to do in science
and so much that i want to do in science
and
and then uh popularization and and
communication to the public it's just
um i know that i i'm being you know
tongue-in-cheek about it but
but you know use this as an example of
that's where the real difference will be
made i think in the future is
just we just need leaders who can lead
in a way that makes some kind and i
would work with anyone i'm hoping to
cultivate a brand as you say
as people say where we'll be i don't
care
i don't yeah do that exactly i i want to
do that and i'm open to whoever wins the
president by the north trump
i don't care i am at your service
because i am patriotic and again
i only know science i don't know you
know social policy and
and and engineering but use me as a
resource
uh if there happened to be watching i'm
more than delighted to serve my
patriotic duty
uh would be through what i could do for
science and communication of science
okay well before you have to go let me i
want to highlight something hans milling
has said um
and thank you by the way hans for the
super chat help i do appreciate it
really every penny helps so thank you so
much
for contributing uh he's making a
comment we have seen lots of papers come
out with results or conclusions before
the research was done
and often with some wrong conclusions
that was later withdrawn
how often has the new earth been found
for example
it makes people distrust the papers um
and
the news and i i i think you're probably
right hans but my i would also add to
that that i think a big
scientists are under a different kind of
pressure these days
with the funding that brian just talked
about where it comes from
there is such a rush to get out papers
um
and and brian so what do you think about
do you think the quality of our science
i mean implied in that comment is that
our science isn't as good as it used to
be
right our papers are being rejected and
and they're being uh
you know corrected all the time do you
think the quality of science is
deteriorating
i i think i think no i think this
quality of science is increasing and
improving the issue that he's
mentioning which i think is a very
astute observation
is the notion of sensationalism and
publicity
and because there's such a a small
amount
of research funding and of attention
that the public has
for understanding especially complex
attributes of scientific and modern
scientific enterprise
uh that what happens is you have this
cycle of funding violence i call it
where you've got
a scientist will be thinking to you know
herself oh i got cool result
and then and then she might talk to the
university uh press office
in her division you know physical
sciences say in my case
and then they might take that and say
let me take it to the union tribune here
in san diego and see if they're
interested
and then maybe it gets picked up by a
national newspaper and you saw this with
our conversation
last month if that never made it to the
guardian of 36 alien civilizations
uh you know if that now he didn't
kristen actually you know intend for
that to happen
but once it started to happen it's very
difficult to resist that now
that's something speculative right
nobody's going to falsify that and say
actually
uh professor console is you're wrong you
should be fired because there's 35 civil
you know
you know scientists need to um get uh
get
attention in a good way not not as you
know publicity hounds but but they
really do need to because if the public
stops supporting science
but i think the bigger point that that
you're making is a good one that if we
undermine our credibility
the whole thing is at risk right and so
we need to be accountable and and that's
why i've proposed you know that
scientists have
a budget of every grant for retractions
you know basically like we had this big
announcement
and it was on the front page of the new
york times and cnn and and there was no
there was no uh coverage whatsoever when
we retry it was on page b17 of the
saturday which
you know when we basically had to admit
that what we had seen was not what we
originally thought it was
and let's not let's not forget to
mention the the
egregious role the media plays in
science communication these days it is
ridiculous how many papers come out and
the scientists
who published i mean you'll read an
article about someone's research and
even the
the first author is perplexed what yeah
how did you get that
from what and even that's uh i was
talking about understanding of
what james what james altitude about you
know it's basically
we don't realize this but behind the
scenes of many of these websites where
people get news
they're doing what's called a b testing
they're testing the headline
so in the millisecond that it takes you
know a cohort of a million people to
check a website
half a million will get one version you
know um
so and so says don't wear a mask so and
so says mass hurt you and then they'll
see which one does better
and they uh the news is the biggest
culprit i feel
in this um in this and kind of negative
attention
circular circular sense of argument i do
want to mention
uh are there any more questions i don't
want to skip over any questions i didn't
see any questions just some comments so
larry met both uh yeah
andrew and yeah so that's how he met
that probably got it on there
voyager development team very cool um
fountain pen he transferred it to gold
that's amazing
uh brian pendley sang on my channel
about
um you know uh and mojos is saying
yeah science is the politics of
scientists and that's a good point you
know it's not the science that's in
question it's
when science gets politicized or when
scientists become political
i find those both to be you know every
four years mark my words tony
in about four months we're going to have
uh an essay in the new york times
from 70 nobel prize winners about who we
should vote for for president
i guarantee it it's like clockwork every
four years yeah well that goes back to
my with my original point you know this
this business of scientists need to talk
about science
and your point as well right why would
you ask a cosmologist about global
warming you know ask
you know ask or or where you said
whether a mask or not that
you know ask the right the right
questions because science by
by necessity has gotten incredibly
um uh what is the word when you're super
specialized i guess you know when you
really hyper specialization right i mean
when you do your work
in cosmology you're doing it in a very
narrow band aren't you
yeah i mean you're by because you want
to get something done you want to
contribute we know the big picture now
right we need your hanging
fruits right yeah so so
you can't you can't be an expert on
everything you can
think thing that you have and then when
it becomes emotional it gets it gets
dangerous
so i do want to make an announcement
that uh next week and the following week
on tuesday i'm going to have
announcements on my youtube channel
and on my twitter account dr brian
keating for both of those
uh we're doing an amazing webinar tony
uh
back by your demand i set this up tony
so you owe me
big time it's going to be with pbs space
time studios
and we're doing a webinar with seven
of the most foremost uh scientists
physicists in the world
about theories of everything do we need
them
why are they important uh and uh if so
what would they look like are there
alternatives
the people that we're gonna have are uh
guests that you
we've talked about in the past uh eric
weinstein
lisa randall uh we're gonna have sabine
hossenfelder
my friend best friend stefan alexander
uh james beecham uh who's a particle
experimentalist
uh lee smolin who's a phenomenal
influence on so many of us in physics
and uh and max tegmark so we've got
seven of the world's top physicists so
look for announcements
subscribe to my mailing list you get an
invitation to it it'll be free
but uh but subscribe to my mailing list
to get to get uh
together how do i do that is is it just
on your website
just i'm going to put it in the in the
chat but yeah it's it's just go to
briankeating.com and it will pop
up ask you to sign up and then i'm going
to send blast out over the weekend
link information for the uh for the
webinars
there's two of them they'll be on
tuesday tuesday afternoon eastern time
this coming tuesday and then the
following tuesday it'll be early in the
morning like
7 30 pacific time 10 30 eastern time
and these are just uh it's going to be
such an exciting thing and i want to
thank you because you're
you're continuing to press me on do we
need this philosophically what would it
look like
how could you test it or not it's really
at the heart of modern physics and i
hope to plan
to have another series about the
multiverse and many worlds so
yeah people get on the mailing list get
interested in it and uh hope to see you
there it'll be free we're going to have
conference proceedings
for people that are interested it's
going to be a blast that'll be nice
for tuesday july 23. that's that's
really cool i'm glad you're getting it
yeah i gotta make it further
so stay tuned sign up i'll put the link
in now
in the chat and please keep it there and
uh and then
enter to win the copy of anne's book and
you can enter
you'll also get on my mailing list so
please do that
and into the impossible is the podcast
dr brian keating on youtube
and uh briankeating.com thank you
everybody
looking forward to this next week again
we'll maybe we'll do a recap of part one
of the toe set webinar
yes that sounds great okay and uh you
you're going to come up with a date soon
too
or did you uh oh the date is uh is july
28th
oh it's okay and august 4th okay um so
stay tuned for the
link details and how you get on it next
week in the following and the following
yeah
okay good yeah all right excellent okay
definitely so
all right well that dr brian keating
from uh uh university of san diego thank
you for taking time out to join us and
talk about your
all the cool stuff you got going on
because i i love talking with you every
week you're easy to talk it's so much
fun
if i feel more comfortable i can just
sort of yell at you a little bit and
you'll be like yeah man
and i'm like your research assistant
right i'm putting together webinars i
would
yes doing good work you're doing good
work son
tony thank you all thank all the
listeners out there please keep in touch
have a safe weekend
i love you all bye guys bye-bye we'll
see ya
okay and i will be um just
i'll be signing off too but i want to
thank you guys for watching we're back
uh periodically here on thursdays when i
can i just got done
uh with the american astronautical
societies glenn symposium last week
that's what i've been
uh that's what i've been uh doing and
yes galaxia to answer your question you
can chat in a webinar because i just got
through
working on that very project last week
so i know that you can chat in a webinar
so definitely sign up and and
participate sounds like a lot of fun
and uh for those of you who don't know i
have a twitch channel and i
am streaming more on that than i am
on youtube these days